photo sharing platform be real has been
number one in the free apps category on
apple's iphone app store for weeks out
ranking bigger social networking apps
like tick tock instagram and facebook
and similar apps lock it and live in
have followed that trajectory racking up
more than 44 million downloads within
months of launching but what's driving
their popularity and will they be around
long enough to compete with more
established social apps let's chat about
that
apple's ios 14 release in 2020 was
significant because it let users add
widgets to their home screen for the
first time it opened the door for a new
class of social apps like be real lock
it and live in these companies promote
themselves as places for people looking
for more privacy and more authentic
interactions
be real even advertises that there are
no filters no likes no followers and no
ads users tell me they like that there's
no pressure to figure out your brand or
aesthetic or a caption there aren't
trends to try or challenges to pursue
it's just you and your friends but app
creators still have two hurdles to
overcome in their quest for longevity
first figuring out a way to monetize
their apps without wrecking the intimate
user experience people have come to know
the apps don't have ads now but that may
not always be the case
when i spoke to the cmo of the social
media marketing firm sprout social she
said they will probably take the more
tried and true advertising strategy and
feature so think about ads like in feed
images or video based ads that you
typically see on other platforms
monetizing is an inevitable progression
for pretty much all apps and be real's
investors will expect the platform to
make money at some point for more
established brands like instagram
facebook and tick tock hosting popular
influencers and businesses through ads
is core to the revenue structure
those apps also started out without ads
but eventually had to sell out to keep
growing and second be real locket and
live-in have to figure out how they're
gonna make money before one of the
bigger players copies them remember vine
the app was one of the first to bring
short form video to the masses a decade
ago
in 2012 twitter bought it and the next
year instagram added a competing video
player and after three years twitter
shut vine down we've also seen instagram
launch snapchat competing stories
twitter launched clubhouse like spaces
these things happen a lot the new social
apps could also try one other thing paid
subscriptions
but who knows if people are willing to
pay for a home screen photo widget that
they've already gotten for free will be
real live in or lock it be able to
overcome these challenges before the
next big app trend comes along
it's really hard to say they're all so
new
but
they do work well enough i added a
couple months ago to keep in touch with
friends and family and i must say
sometimes getting a surprise home screen
photo beats opening an app and sending a
text